do you have favorite characters that
you've played Yahoo that's not fair to
the other think a baby was your favorite
baby
well obviously obviously Muriel is right
up there because of who she is because
of who she becomes or who she returns to
depends on which way you look at it
despite all the odds that's really
empowering to me and I love that it's
you know this beautiful story but
between two women I mean it's not Angie
Bowie but I'm pretty much was energy
Bowie I loved making velvet goldmine I
mean also Todd Haynes hired me and I
really was not you know I'll be an
obvious choice at all so I always felt
very flattered that he allowed me that
experience well this is not a film but I
did show called United States of Tara
[Applause]
I loved all of my characters but how
much fun is it to be just a shitty
little teenager I loved playing tea she
was outrageous um one of my favorite
directors I ever worked with
was Curtis so even tonight in her shoes
is the film Curtis Hanson directed he
was so thorough I often find ya
rehearsal a little bit of a waste of
time because most directors are a bit
afraid and don't quite know what they
want to do with you and he just used his
time so thoroughly it was so insightful
and it was really really satisfying and
even tonight as I just talked to his
enemies backstage but as I was getting
ready in my hotel room a bunch of
friends came over including Cameron Diaz
who plays my sister and she literally at
one point she was like fussing around
all those earrings a great where that no
don't worry about um and I was kind of
figuring out what she was gonna wear she
said what size are you what size of
shoes are you [ __ ] kidding me we just
did a whole film
anyway she offered her alive
and I actually decline into terrible one
little aside about that movie in
rehearsals was that Curtis was I think
the only director I've ever worked with
who included the writer in rehearsals
and I have this great memory of you
sitting there slurping down a giant
milkshake because you were putting on
weight for the role and I think I think
it was you know you slurped made a noise
and surely looked at you a little funny
and you looked at her and said I'm
working here
[Laughter]